what's up everybody welcome back to
gamespot cross kind of funny here at
gamespot com / III I'm Greg that's Colin
and this is aaron greenberg from my xbox
himself look at they love you out here
they're clapping like crazy for a urine
how are you I'm doing great how about
you guys weirdo thank you we're excited
to be here congratulations what a great
press conference thank you you guys
killed it thank you yeah at what point
did you think you had something special
we've been working on it for a long time
yeah team work really hard on this and I
would say you know we locked the show
about a week ago yeah in the last week
and at that point we felt good but
frankly until we see the fans and the
reaction from folks like you guys we we
never really know yeah I was super
impressed eames like you guys had
focused not only on the games but on
Xbox one as a device and listening to
the fans and updating and so had it it
wasn't easy to balance you know the need
to obviously show products yeah along
with saying hey if you already own one
will hear is what we're doing with it as
well I mean that's totally what this
holidays about for us is like there's
tens of millions of people that own an
xbox 360 we know a lot of them been
waiting to upgrade if they've been
waiting for halo we have halo 5 they've
been waiting for Gears we're bringing
gears they've been waiting I've been
waiting for backwards compatibility yeah
bringing that as well so we think we
know with all the exclusives all the
games coming this year now is kind of
the time and we expect a lot of those
people to migrate and hopefully that
kind of made it through that's really
our big focus is holiday is to primarily
get those people to move over and and
welcome new fans as well well I mean
what is right now in your mind at least
the character of xbox you know what I
mean there's been a lot of changes
layton you guys are right now I think
killing it on all fronts what how do you
describe what's happening there well you
know it really starts on the top I mean
Phil Spencer has just been a fantastic
leader to take over the Xbox business
you saw him in that role for the first
time at e3 last year and you know all of
us here they've been working on the
business for a long time we love our
fans and we really want to put fans at
the center of everything we do and I
think if you look at the way we show up
look at the games are investing in we
look at the monthly updates the feedback
that's really how we're building our
business and so that's how I like to
kind of think about our brand is really
focused on the fans first and the kind
of the business and second put the fans
first you'll be all right in the long
term is it is it difficult to kind of be
a you guys are a big company within a
big company right and your big
organization I say our group with
they come is it difficult to kind of be
nimble and move around because I've been
super impressed with watching xbox one
evolved over these last year and a half
or even really two years since it was
revealed and I think a lot of people
thought that there were significant
missteps when it was revealed and yet
everything's kind of changed is it
difficult for a company as big as yours
to kind of move that quickly because
I've certainly been impressed watching
it well we have a really really tight
team and so our leadership team is super
tight the people that work on those
products you know and we we are giving
the gaming group is a dedicated gaming
group so while we're part of a bigger
company and there's a lot of resources
we can use if it's about as your cloud
or there's other types of infrastructure
we want to use or we built you know we
built our platform on on the windows OS
but there's a lot of those benefits but
today the way we focus on studios and
content and updates and all that